un second débat tout de suite dans ce
sens publiques consacrées au cabinet de
conseil les conclusions de la commission
d' enquête du sénat dénonçant je cite un
système tentaculaire et opaques sont
devenues un enjeu de cette campagne
présidentielle et hier soir deux
ministres ont tenté de décoller le spar
à la du costume des manuels macron sagna
de chiens
dégonfler la polémique à tout prix hier
amélie de montchanin et olivier dussopt
pts ont organisé une conférence de
presse de dernière minute devant les
journalistes ils sont revenus sur le
recours au cabinet de conseil à qui le
gouvernement a versé plus d'un milliard
d'euros l'an dernier d'après les
révélations du sénat une pratique
normale d'après les ministres qui assure
que ces cabinets n'ont eu aucune
influence sur les décisions de
l'exécutif se bornant à un simple rôle
de conseil
jamais jamais d'abord on se cache
derrière un cabinet conseil prend une
décision
jamais on laisse la décision à une autre
personne qu'un ministre aucun directeur
d'administration qui est dans les
prérogatives très clair d'application de
ce qui est sa responsabilité
est donc la première chose que moi je
suis venu vous dire ce soir c'est que
nous ne nous sommes pas des saisies de
nos responsabilités les ministres
n'auraient rien à cacher de leur recours
au cabinet de conseil qui ont fait
l'objet de quatre mois dans quête par le
sénat le gouvernement fait toute la
transparence sur l'ensemble des
informations qui ont été demandés par la
commission enquête tous les chiffres ont
été donnés tous les contrats tous les
bons de commande ont été transmis toutes
les productions internes ont été
communiqués ce sont des milliers de
courriers électroniques cette opération
de déminage fait sourire eliane assassi
la rapporteure de la commission d'
enquête du sénat à l'origine des
révélations des révélations qui visitent
en partie le cabinet mckinsey soupçonné
de ne pas payer l'impôt sur les sociétés
en france et dont l'un des dirigeants a
soutenu la campagne des menus et le
maquereau il y a cinq ans je trouve que
la mise en scène hier soir était assez
incroyable c'est à dire deux ministres
en pleine période électorale à quelques
jours du premier tour de la
présidentielle qui se croient obligés de
venir défendre l'indéfendable s'il
devait faire la transparence qui nous
donne l'entièreté des livrables
qu'il nous dise si c'est avéré que
mackinsey ne paient pas d'impôts depuis
au moins dix ans qu'il nous dise si
mckinsey fait l'objet d'un contrôle
fiscal et depuis quand voilà donc il ya
encore beaucoup beaucoup d'opacité sur
sur cette affaire une loi est désormais
en préparation au sénat pour mieux
encadrer et contrôler le recours au
cabinet de conseil par le gouvernement
elle devrait être présentée à l'automne
et on débat autour de cette polémique
mckinsey le sparadrap d' emmanuel macron
pour l'interrogation voilà le titre de
ce débat et je vous présente mes invités
nos invités gilles cabrol bonsoir
bienvenue cette déléguée générale de
l'aurore cercle de réflexion
républicains et progressistes et auteur
de ce livre dans le silence de l'état
publié aux édition de l'observatoire
entonne rouget bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste à mediapart et vous n'est
publié un article sur les relations
entre le cabinet mckinsey emmanuel
macron c'était ce jeudi après midi
matthieu courtecuisse bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes entrepreneur investisseurs à
la tête du cabinet de conseil en
stratégie en intelligence artificielle
sia partners et président de sint et de
conseils c'est le syndicat qui
représente les cabinets de conseil en
fédérations sainteté sable saintais
qu'on dise à
la française syntec conseil c'est une
fédération laetitia cru pas lutter et
d'esthétique toujours mes côtés il n'y a
rien à cacher les règles ont été
respectées qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cet axe de défense du gouvernement hier
jean bondi sur la conférence de presse
des deux ministres aubin ce qu'ils
disent qu'il ya c'est que
on sentait depuis quelques jours qu'il
fallait monter au créneau du côté du
gouvernement pour tenter d'éteindre les
incendies enfin la petite flamme au
début mais enfin qui est en train de
prendre des proportions quand même
importante alors c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qui est très complexe qui est tout
à fait légitime parce que l'utilisation
encore à des des prestations externes
par l'état par la puissance publique en
général c'est un vrai sujet évidemment
on n'est pas dans le contexte seulement
idéal à dix jours du premier tour de la
présidentielle pour poser des questions
très très compliqué dans les conditions
de sérénité de neutralité d'objectivité
les meilleurs mais bon c'est comme ça il
faut bien répondre et maintenant il faut
mettre un certain nombre de choses sur
la table certainement et c'est
l'occasion de débattre aussi sur
l'affaiblissement de l'état ce sera là
là là notait mais pourquoi finalement
au-delà du cas macron des ministres ont
tendance à faire appel au cabinet de
conseil matthieu courtecuisse sur le
principe on peut tout à fait défendre
cet appel au cabinet conseil
al'expertise en transformation que vous
pouvez avoir sur des cabinets sur des
compétences spécifiques
est ce que vous pensez quand même ce que
j'imagine que vous avez touché le
rapport de la commission d' enquête du
sénat est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya eu
des abus potentiels
dans l' usage de ces cabinets de conseil
parle par l'état dont ce rapport à
intéressant du sénat il ya aussi une
part qui concerne l'évaluation d'un
certain nombre d'un panel de missions
qui ont été réalisés et ses missions
était plutôt bien notés entre quatre et
cinq sur cinq pour plus des trois quarts
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya par rapport à
un besoin qui a été exprimée il ya une
réponse qui a été apportée et qui a été
jugée plutôt satisfaisante nous on est
un peu étonné de l'accusation de doper
cité de notre profession parce que
d'abord là c'est chypre qui
correspondent à ce qui a été publié par
le sénat est confirmée par le
gouvernement dont il donne depuis plus
de vingt ans sans aucun problème donc
alors que chaque année on peut savoir
pour ce public doit valoir entre
guillemets quand ça ne donne pas
évidemment cabinet par cabinet parce que
l on donne le marché mais on le donne
aussi pour non seulement pour l'état
mais aussi que les collectivités
territoriales or la commission
sénatoriale a refusé d'examiner la
dépense de conseil dans les
collectivités territoriales qu'est ce
que ça représente en conversion si on
parle d'un milliard alors pour l'état et
ccct convient les colore en fait
territoriale il ya le sujet de
l'assiette qu'on n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord non plus avec le sénat parce
que dedans il intègre la réalisation
d'outils informatiques
or le lait la commission avait pour
objet d'étudier l'influencé sur les
politiques publiques qui nous semble pas
que réaliser une application
informatique l'exploiter la maintenir ce
soit très en lien avec une influence en
plus ce n'est pas forcément les mêmes
des entreprises qui font qu'ils font ça
donc en gros ce que confirme le rapport
du sénat est ce que confirme le
gouvernement on est autour de 400 à 500
millions par an de dépenses de conseil
en stratégie et en management pour
l'état il ya en plus de ça entre 100 et
150 millions qui concerne les
collectivités territoriales et cette
partie là est en croissance moi je note
quand même moi je fais pas de politique
mais il ya apparemment deux candidats à
la présidentielle qui sont la tête de
collectivités territoriales et enfin je
dirais qu'il ya aussi il utilise donc le
cabinet de conseil bain à bois par
exemple mon cabinet a déjà mon cabinet a
déjà travaillé pour pour la région
ile-de-france sur suite aux attentats
terroristes du bas du bataclan enfin
l'analyse des sentiments des touristes
chinois sur les dix monuments principaux
la région parisienne voyez pour
anticiper la baisse de la fréquentation
est ensuite et les opérateurs donc la
cnam le pôle emploi etc qui représentent
à peu près 200 millions alors faut
comparer avec les autres pays parce que
c'est pas un cas isolé la france est ce
que dit aussi le rapport du sénat c'est
que au fond bahreïn si on compare avec
l'allemagne c'est un facteur 3 ou 4 donc
on était trois fois plus au canada et en
allemagne idem pour le royaume uni je ne
parle même pas des pays nord américains
bon ok on va est ce que dans votre
exercice de transparence vous publiez
aussi les fiches d'impôts c'est à dire
est ce qu on sait qu il paye ses impôts
alors ça et ça c'est bien mais sauf que
ce thème là il vient un peu plus tard
dans le débat donc je donc on y
reviendra sur la question et notamment
de l'a22 mckinsey ce que mc kinsey paye
ses impôts en france ou pas mais c'est
une bonne question donc on va là posé
mais j'aurais quand même entendre en
tonneau j'ai vous allez on va on va
venir au contenu de votre dernier
article mais peut-être d'une manière
générale quand vous abordez le dossier
qu'est ce qui vous surprend qu'est ce
qui vous choque dans dans l' enquête de
la commission du du sénat et dans les
premières révélations qui sont faites à
roche je trouve qu'il est extrêmement
intéressant dans le rapport du sénat
devoir c'est un effet d'accumulation et
je pense que c'est ça qui c'est pour ça
que l'opinion s'en empare au delà du
contexte électoral et ça c'est c'est à
dire que la question des cabinets de
conseil elle n'est pas nouvelle
l'importance des missions de certaines
missions des cabinets de conseil elle
voir le rôle stratégique qui leur
étaient parfois confié au détriment
finalement deux circuits de décision au
sein d'un appareil d'état c'est pas
nouveau il ya eu des questionnements
déjà des enquêtes qui ont été publiés là
dessus mais là c'est vrai que
rapport du sénat vient donner une
épaisseur à ce questionnement là et avec
des exemples très concrets qui sont qui
sont extrêmement marquant on va parler
après d'échelle et de la fameux
milliards d'euros avec finalement des
interprétations différentes au regard
notamment emmanuel macron et son
entourage le rappel regard de la dépense
publique en france et donc explique que
ça représente 0 3% de la dépense totale
de la masse salariale pendant de l'état
mais mais mais ce qui met ce qui est
extrêmement ce que retiennent ce que
retiennent les citoyens et qui se sont
intéressés à ce sujet là à l'aune du
rapport du sénat ce cd exemple
extrêmement concret par exemple sur
l'éducation nationale sur l'hôpital sur
la santé là où on a vu y compris dans la
crise qu'ovide récente que que l'état
était complètement démuni quand on voit
que quand on voit que des cabinets de
conseils on pourra citer maclean's et
mais d'autres touches 500000 euros par
exemple sur des missions dont on peine à
évaluer le le contour et qui sont
pointés par clairement identifiés par la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale on
comprend d'un côté le pouvoir politique
en place dix mais ça représenterait 1
500 mille euros au regard de de ce conte
de ce qu'on dépense et de stamm et
aimait al'inverse en leur centre ici on
a l'impression que le rapport
est creux on va lui dire ça je veux dire
ça comme ça en l'occurrence était celui
sur l'éducation nationale êtres humains
ont fait la différence on y reviendra il
parlant des impôts et issia web n'est
pas loin du moment où je voulais
l'évoqué dans l'assurance 16 ans dans ce
débat oui bien sûr avec d'abord parce
que ce que nous dit le le sénat
et ça concerne la le cabinet mckinsey
soyons précis impôt sur les sociétés
zéro euro depuis au moins dix ans
chiffre d'affaires en france 329
millions d'euros 600 salariés depuis
mckinsey a réagi en disant notamment
qu'une de ses filiales à payer l'impôt
sur les sociétés pendant six ans en
france sur la décennie
concernés si j'ai bien compris matthieu
courtecuisse que sco c'est ce qu'on
appelle les prix de transfert versée par
les entités françaises à leur maison
mère pour minorer leurs résultats et
donc payer moins d'impôts en france
point 1 parce que c'est quand même
important de le rappeler est ce que
c'est légal c'est tout à fait légal
soumis à certaines conditions alors moi
je connais pas la situation fiscale de
matrix et en particulier je peux vous
parler de la mienne oui pour moi j'ai
créé mon entreprise on est de 1500
personnes dans le monde un peu plus de
1000 en france 50% hors france et donc
le siège donc qui en france facture des
prix de transfert pour des services des
prêts de consultant à mes autres entités
dans l'est dans le reste du monde et
donc en fait moi je veux major mon
résultat en france et je me nord mon
résultat à dans d'autres pays donc ça
c'est la même chose partout oui mais
donc c'est effectivement un moyen légal
on l'a bien compris mais pour mckinsey
de minorer son chiffre d'affaires
français pour payer moins d'impôts en
france pas son chiffre d'affaires sa
profitabilité d'accord mais encore une
fois ça va dépendre des sièges de
d'origine des différentes entreprises et
ce qui est important de savoir c'est que
dans la balance des paiements en france
les flux qui reviennent parce qu'on a
beaucoup de grands groupes en france qui
est qu'ils rapatrient des prix de
transfert
et des dividendes et des flux financiers
en france entre ce qui est en moi par
l'épaule et les filiales françaises des
groupes étrangers par rapport à ce que
les groupes français rappatrient la
balance est positif pour la balance des
paiements et donc faut savoir aussi que
ces conventions qui touche aux prix de
transfert elles font l'objet de
d'accords bilatéraux entre les pays
concernés donc il faut prendre la
réflexion dans son ensemble je comprends
que c'est une question complexe et comme
je disais c'est une passion française
mais au delà de la passion 16 on peut
considérer choquant que huit une
entreprise comme mckinsey fasse en sorte
de payer le moins d'impôt en france
surtout quand elles gagné pas mal
d'argent avec l'état alors ça j'irais
quand fait
encore une fois moi je ne veux pas me
prononcer sur ce cas en particulier mais
colle aussi présenté la fédération bon
voilà le renommé alors lire merci
d'accepter l'invitation j'ai pas si
facile d'obtenir des gens pour défendre
les cabinets de conseil en ce moment
dans les débats sur sur ce thème je ne
fais que ça mais mais non mais en fait
bon le siège de mckinsey est basé aux
états unis il ya un certain nombre enfin
là le rapport de la commission montre
que d'ailleurs il ya pas mal de cabinet
de nationalités différentes qui
travaille auprès de l'état mais les plus
gros enfin les plus gros montants en
fait sont davantage vers des cabinets
français que vers des cabinets
étrangers on va venir la question des
conflits d'intérêt est au coeur de votre
article vous entendre gilles clavel sur
le la thématique centrale qui est
d'ailleurs celle de votre livre dans le
silence de de l'état ça ça pose en creux
la question de l'efficacité ou même de
la reconnaissance des administrations
centrales par l'opinion par leurs
ministres c'est vraiment une question
centrale oui alors en fait il ya deux
choses assez différentes
sur lequel d'ailleurs pour moi le
rapport même s'il ya plein de choses
dedans et pas complètement satisfaisant
il ya la question d'éventuelles
malversations abus
c'était ça ou conflits d'intérêts
là-dessus bon il est tout à fait
légitime qu'on s'en préoccupe mais il
n'y a rien de très tangible à ce stade
en tout cas moi j'ai pas j'ai partagé
des rapports pas très bon voire
franchement mauvais oui ça il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont en pointe et c'est
pas la majorité des cas mais il y en a
évidemment ça pose la question de
comment ça a été piloté qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour pour éventuellement récupérer
l'argent du contribuable mais enfin c
c'est relativement marginal et puis à la
question de l'opportunité et
véritablement et ça le rapport ne répond
pas vraiment en fait on a l'impression
qu'on est un peu dans une position
dogmatique en disant l'état ne doit pas
recourir à des prestations de conseil
c'est pas vrai parce qu'en réalité dans
bien des cas il en a besoin il peut pas
mais il peut pas faire autrement j'ai
compris je trouve pas parce qu'il n'ya
pas les expertises alors soit il n'ya
pas il n'ya pas les expertises et il n'y
a pas lieu de d'avoir une expertise au
sein de l'état de manière permanente et
le sujet informatique et d'un bond cher
parce qu' il faudrait en fait des
bataillons d'ingénieurs en permanence
que vous recrutez que vous formez et
c'est que vous gardez pendant 40 ans
mais que vous n'avez pas utilisé de
manière permanente entre deux projets de
rénovation informatique donc on fait
appel à des expertises co n'a pas à
l'état et c'est normal et c'est moins
cher au total pour un point un produit
fini qui va être en principe meilleur
pareil quand vous avez des montées en
charge extrêmement rapide ou des
situations de crise je dirais que plutôt
le fait qu'il y est eu des carences au
début de la gestion du coc vide dans
dans certains dispositifs bas c'est
plutôt en appui d'un recours à un
prestataire externe par exemple pour
gagner du temps sur des chaînes
logistiques n'existait pas importer des
situations qui ont lu ailleurs donc là
cette dent dans ces cas-là l'utilisation
du conseil et est pertinente en revanche
le problème c'est quoi quand l'état ne
sait pas vraiment ce qu'il veut ou qu'il
a besoin où la puissance publique parce
que c'est la question des collectivités
locales et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
dommage je n'ai pas abordés ou bien il
sait pas vraiment ce qu'il veut et il
attend que le consultant le lui dise ou
bien il sait ce qu'il veut mais il a
peur de ne pas être légitime est en
quelque sorte va chercher une expertise
pour se légitimer ses des problématiques
d'ailleurs qui existent pareil dans le
secteur privé
sociologue qui s'appelle françois dupuis
qui a écrit il ya quelques années et qui
s'appelle lost in management qui est
passionnant il décrit sa effectivement
des consultants qui apporte
littéralement le la stratégie que les
patrons n'arrive pas à n'arrive pas à
trouver lorsque l'état est un peu
embrouillé dans ces objectifs ont ils
n'arrivent pas à légitimer les décisions
impopulaires difficile complexe
techniquement pour le public ou pour ses
propres agents alors en effet il ya une
tentation du recours au conseil c'est là
qu'est un problème éventuel il ya un bon
cas d'école je rappelle tient simplement
pour qu'on prenne reprenne conscience du
travail de la commission denquête cesser
ces chiffres sur le nombre d'auditions
le nombre de personnes entendues 40
audition 47 personnes entendues 7300
documents analysés quatre mois d'enquêté
puis alors il ya eu des échanges qui
était particulièrement intéressant et on
va faire un focus sur ce que vous
évoquez ltte leur salaire la question de
l'éducation nationale écoutez ce face à
face entre ayant assassi sénatrice
communiste de seine-saint-denis qu'est
rapporteur de la commission et le
directeur associé de mckinsey au bureau
de paris regardez vous avez obtenu un
contrat d'un montant de 496 1800 euros
pour je cite
évaluer les évolutions du métier
d'enseignant d'enseignants vous pouvez
nous dire à quoi aboutit cette mission
qu'il s'agissait d'une part de travaux
de benchmarking de comparaison de quels
avaient été les évolutions faites à un
somme de pays européens pour anticiper
les évolutions de milliers d'enseignants
et donc réfléchir un certain nombre de
thèmes de réflexion qui était prévue
pour la tenue d'un séminaire avec les
responsables enseignants étaient pris en
février 2021
vous l'avez évoqué la question des notes
alexandre plus à vous pouvez nous nous
rejoindre parce que effectivement ce
rapport comme tous les autres îles et
les notes fait partie des jeux trouve
des désinformations ça vous assez
savoureuse ceux de ce rapport de la
commission denquête les travaux des
cabinets de conseil sont notés
effectivement chaque mission confiée à
un cabinet de conseil est notée par
l'état et il y a des missions qui sont
vraiment mal notés on va prendre
quelques exemples par exemple une
mission réalisée par le cabinet
capgemini pour organiser ce qu'on
appelle la communauté 360 c'est un
réseau de professionnels pour soutenir
les personnes en situation de handicap
la note donnée à cette mission un sur
cinq commentaire cinglant je le cite
valeur ajoutée quasi nul contre
productif parfois mais peut-on lire dans
l'évaluation les consultants étaient des
personnes de bonne compagnie alors à une
mission avec un coût de 280 mille euros
ça fait quand même un petit peu cher là
pour la bonne compagnie autre fiasco une
mission confiée au cabinet inox pour
transformer la direction générale des
entreprises c'est l'une des directions
les plus importantes de bercy au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
mission pareil à noter un sur cinq dans
l'est dans l'évaluation faite par l'état
avec l'appréciation suivante manque de
rigueur absence de pilotage par le
manager nombreux livrables c'est à dire
les documents produits par le cabinet
d'une qualité irrecevable et le problème
c'est que cette mission a coûté à la
puissance publique 373 1000 euros mais
il ya quand même des missions qui sont
pas trop mal notés et pourtant si on va
avoir l'appréciation ça en dit long sur
le travail effectué cette rêverie quand
on regarde dans les détails de
l'évaluation et bien il y à redire avec
par exemple le cabinet roland berger
guerre qui a effectué une mission sur le
projet des 1000 premiers jours de
l'enfant en gros c'est la politique de
la petite enfance du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron à la mission effectuée
par ce cabinet a été notée avec la
moyenne deux ennemis sur 5 mais le
commentaire est plutôt négatif pas au
niveau la valeur ajoutée sur le scénario
de chiffrage n'est pas à la hauteur je
cite d'un cabinet de stratégie
le coût de cette mission 425 mille euros
et puis enfin regardons une mission
confiée là encore à la gros cabinet
capgemini pour créer la direction
numérique du ministère de l'intérieur la
note est de 3 sur 5 mais en réalité
cette mission et je cite un faible
apport sur le fond elle les consultants
ont eu une expertise limité à porter sur
la transformation numérique et un manque
de souplesse face aux
prévu du projet avec là encore une
addition salée à 3 142 mille euros merci
alexandre alors voulait me dire matthieu
courtecuisse qu'on a montré que les
exemples négative c'est ça si vous
disiez globalement c'était mieux notés
bah si vous faites la course à la place
pour le gentil si effectivement on parle
souvent des haut parleurs rarement des
trains qui arrivent à l'heure voilà donc
ce qui est important de comprendre c'est
que nous on est révocable a notamment
c'est à dire que une mission quand il se
passe pas très bien le pouvoir du client
le privilège de l'acheteur c'est
d'arrêter ce cette mission contester son
paiement et surtout de révoquer
potentiellement le cabinet de conseil et
nous on est tout à fait ouvert à ces
évaluations d'ailleurs la plupart de nos
clients privés font exactement la même
chose nos missions sont extrêmement
souvent évaluée et dont on n'a aucun
problème avec avec ça et les ailes et
les capacités contractuels sont offertes
à l'état sont tout à fait flexible
est-ce qu'il faut changer et finalement
parce que la question c'est est-ce que
même quand c'est pas bon on continue de
de faire travailler certains de ces
cabinets de conseil peut-être pas je
sais pas si c'est une espèce de routine
ou de force de l'habitude qui a été
prise par certaines administrations oui
c'est aussi lui faudra regarder en
détail administration par administration
la solution de facilité en quelque sorte
quoi peut-être ou tout simplement parce
que il n'ya pas tant de cabinet qui
peuvent répondre à un moment donné à une
besoin une commande précise et puis les
conditions contractuelles sont quand
même beaucoup moins souple que dans le
privé on est encadré par le code des
marchés publics ni est globalement très
contraignant et tous les acheteurs
publics vous le diront peut-être pas en
homme et vous le diront aof et donc on a
un cadre contractuel qui n'est pas si
protecteur que ça pour la puissance
publique alors on va parler maintenant
de cette question de d'éventuels
conflits d'intérêts ont en tout cas de
la proximité entre emmanuel macron et le
directeur associé de mckinsey karim
tadjeddine c'est évidemment au coeur des
conséquences politiques de ce dossier
yat-il conflit d'intérêts à écouter eric
zemmour ce matin c'est sur rtl
emmanuel macron a utilisé une vingtaine
de membres du cabinet mckinsey pendant
sa campagne électorale de 2010 est il la
fait ils l'ont fait à titre gratuit donc
c'était déjà une ovine une
légalité puisque on sait le prix de ses
conseillers et ont ils n'ont pas à
travailler gratuitement et comme par
hasard parce que vous me dites que ça
existait avant oui mais les chiffres
parlent en 2018 on paye à mckinsey
l'état paye à mckinsey 300 millions
d'euros votre journaliste l'a dit tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui c'est un milliard
comme retour d'ascenseur on fait
difficilement mieux je pense qu emmanuel
macron la renvoyer l'ascenseur à
mckinsey qui a travaillé gratuitement
pour sa campagne alors en l'occurrence
yens europe sur les 1 milliard c'est pas
seulement mckinsey et évidemment c'est
plusieurs
plusieurs cabinets de conseils bons en
amérique c'est moins de 20% de leurs
dépôts s'accordent donc là il ya déjà
une erreur qu'il faut évidemment pas
laissé passer messieurs sur la gratuité
des services est ce que ça c'est vrai ce
que ça fait partie de votre enquête je
repars de zéro parce que témoin a
l'habitude quand même de raconter
absolument n'importe quoi donc vaut
mieux repartir sur une base factuelle
scène ce qui s'est passé en 2016 et et
en 2017 c'est que effectivement un
certain nombre de
consultants dont des partenaires de
maquilleuses et dont le directeur
associé calme tadjeddine qu'on a vu tout
à l'heure ont participé à la campagne
des manuels mâcon comment la sucer grâce
aux macronix cette fuite de 10 mail de
la campagne dans laquelle on a vu
apparaître des emails des adresses mails
professionnels du cabinet mckinsey à
quoi on travaillait et sur quoi on
travaille et ses consultants ils ont
travaillé notamment sur l'organisation
de la grande marche et le traitement des
données issues du porte-à-porte réalisé
par les militants en 2016 la réponse de
karim tadjeddine on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est de dire qu' il avait
commis une erreur en utilisant son
adresse mail aux professionnels donc on
peut en déduire que dès que les autres
une salariée de mac intel ayant fait
regrette aussi d'avoir utiliser leurs
adresses mail et d'expliquer qu'il le
faisait bénévolement et qu'il
travaillait bénévolement en dehors de
ses heures de travail en tant que
soutien d' emmanuel macron là où ça
commence à être intéressant est
troublant c'est que
on s'est rendu compte que au même moment
mckinsey avait également offert des
prestations pro bono donc sans
rémunération est sans contrat à emmanuel
macron quand il était encore ministre de
l'économie ont encore avant en 2015 au
moment où il y avait quand les réunions
préparatoires pour pour pour la création
dans marche il y avait des rendez vous à
bercy auxquels karim tadjeddine a
participé et makeen et a délibérément
choisi d'offrir des prestations et de
réaliser des prestations pro bono auprès
d' emmanuel macron d'après des
témoignages qu'on a qu'on a recueilli au
sein de mckinsey dans une stratégie
d'influencé à l'égard de dieu du
ministre futur futur candidat donc il ya
quand même un question en 2015 ils
peuvent pas anticiper sur le fait qu'il
soit candidat non mais y aller crier
allez y avoir il ya les réunions
préparatoires de 2,2 du lancement dans
marché mais évidemment on peut pas
imaginer à la fois qu'il sera candidat
est élu dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles président de la
république mais en revanche emmanuel
macron ministre de l'économie et des
finances représente déjà un avenir
politique certains et surtout une une
adéquation en terme de en terme de
philosophie de compréhension et de de ce
qu'est l'état et le rôle de l'état et
des cabinets de conseil dans le voilà
emmanuel macron a une vision très
libérale surtout au sein du camp qui le
représente à l'époque le parti
socialiste et sa et donc il ya à la fois
s'être opportunités d'encadrer ce cette
personnalité politique montante dont on
sait qu'elle va jouer être amené à jouer
un rôle important dans les années dans
les années à venir liées au fait que en
plus on partage une même idéologie et
vision de l'état alors il ya pas mal de
tiroir à ouvrir sur les questions de la
gratuité sur la stratégie des cabinets
de conseil vous lirez agir je vous donne
ma parole pourquoi oui oui parce que là
où je vous suis entonneront ges et si je
crois qu'on touche au fond du sujet 6,7
cette polémique fait autant de autant de
buzz c'est parce qu'elles touchent à
quelque chose qui est assez fondamental
pour les français c'est que l'état c'est
l'état et l'état c'est pas les intérêts
privés et les français sont
historiquement culturellement attaché au
fait qu'ils aient une séparation assez
stricte entre la chose privée et la
chose publique là où peut-être je vous
suis moins cécilia mis un terme
charnière dans votre dans notre
développement c'est le sait le terme d'
influence j'ai envie de vous retourner
la question influence pour quoi faire en
fait c'est à dire qu'elle est quel était
l'intérêt makine sert en fait de
mckinsey dans cette danse est ces
opérations de pro bono en fait y en a
deux si je mets de côté les
interventions personnelles des associés
qui peuvent ainsi impliqué en politique
c'est leur droit il faut y avoir de deux
types d'intérêt soit faire du business
après et là il est pas spécialement
établi qu mckinsey a particulièrement
bénéficié plus que les autres un plus
que d'autres cabinets de deux des
prestations futures puissent se sont
serrés encadrés par des marchés donc par
des maîtres des marchés des grands
marchés publics donc ça veut dire appel
d'offres ou alors ou alors il ya une
autre c'est peut-être à ça que vous
pensiez un peu plus l'idée que mc kinsey
au fonds participe de la propagation
d'une idéologie plus favorable au marché
est plus libérale c'est peut-être ça que
que vous vouliez dire bon là c'est une
affaire d'appréciation politique
pourquoi pas mais on n'est plus du tout
vous voyez bien on n'est plus du tout
dans le débat de malversations de
collusion et c'est autre chose c'est un
autre c'est un autre débat plus
intéressant d'ailleurs et c'est pour ça
que j'aime
si on peut espérer quelque chose que le
débat se déplace ou serez hausse vers
vers des sujets de principe de cette
nature est ce que vous parlez de
malversations dont parle pas de
malversation on parle d'un contexte qui
est extrêmement intéressant à analyser à
l'eau à l'aune des révélations faites
par le par la commission sénatoriale
vous dites que le que maclean's et n'a
pas spécialement profiter il ya
notamment sur les sur les questions de
deux prestations pro bono il ya quand
même une recommandation extrêmement
forte qui dudu du sénat qui est de
prohiber surtout dans ce registre là
quand on est sur des prestations qui
devrait être payante ce type de
prestations gratuites et d'ailleurs hier
olivier dussopt pts et à médine
montchanin ont tenté finalement
d'éteindre la polémique sur sûr sur
cette dimension là en disant
qu'effectivement ça devait être
totalement cadrés et que pour des
prestations absolument exceptionnel
parce que parmi les près les prestations
pro bono quand même qu'ils ont été
réalisés qu'on apprend encore une fois
dans le rapport de la commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale il ya un sommet en
2018 organisé par la présidence de la
république take for blood je crois
qu'ils auquel participent ma kiné à
titre totalement gracieux et la retombée
on la voit immédiatement c'est que
quelques mois plus tard quand mac intel
va répondre à un appel d'offres de
l'ugap la centrale d'achat de l'état on
va mettre dans parmi les parmi les
éléments valorisant mackinsey la
capacité pour mckinsey d'inviter les
cadres de l'udc a pas d à des événements
auxquels il participe encore
organisateurs à la plaisance à
république donc on voit bien qu'il ya un
enjeu de notoriété voire commercial dont
que tire ses cabinets de conseil à
travers ses prestations pro bono société
c'est que l'état il trouve son compte en
fait c'est ça qui doit être déterminée
qui cherche qu'ils fassent leur business
ça me paraît normal mais il faut que
l'état y trouve son compte c'est ça
l'important matthieu courtecuisse
questions précises sur justement le des
contrats pro bono sert le fait de
travailler gratuitement
alors ça peut sembler paradoxale au
profane puisqu'à la fois aux reproches à
l'état de dépenser trop d'argent pour
les cabinets de conseil et puis aussi en
reprochent de les faire travailler
gratuitement
mais est-ce que c'est légal là aussi je
pose un peu les mêmes questions est ce
que ces courants et est ce que la
question est triple vous allez avoir du
temps pour répondre et est ce que il ya
peut-être ce que vous dites une
stratégie une influence derrière ses
rangs la personne à qui on offre ce
cette prestation gratuite le rend
redevables
la proposition du du la commission du
sénat c'est la nôtre fait d'accord qui a
été reprise à la suite de mon audition
au titre donc de syntec oui le premier
point c'est que nous en tant que
syndicat on est contre toute mission pro
bono pour les partis politiques d'accord
et j'arrête pour ça c'est très clair
arty politique pas forcément
administration pour les administrations
dont on a proposé de basculer sur un
régime qui s'appelle les convention de
mécénat parce que les conventions du
mécénat elles permettent de déterminer
un délai de viduité à la fin de la
réalisation d'une mission c'est-à-dire
que vous dites sur un périmètre donné
pendant un an deux ans vous n'avez plus
le droit d'avoir la moindre activité
rémunérée pour pour cette entité et
c'est quelque chose qui existe déjà
beaucoup avec les musées dans le secteur
des associations et dans le cadre des de
l'éducation et on propose de déployer ce
dispositif auprès de l'état est comme ça
sera cadré complètement ouais donc vous
admettez le fait que ça a besoin de
cadres et ah oui tout à fait et on n'a
aucun problème avec ces femmes
politiques directement c'est possible
c'est ce que mais je viens d'expliquer
c'est à dire que enfin au jeu ces partis
politiques au sens
sait plus trop ce que c'est qu'un parti
politique mais mais c'est vrai que non
non non on a clairement indiqué que pour
adhérer aux saintais quand il n'est pas
possible de travailler pro bono pour les
partis politiques de toute façon la
question du pro bono pour les partis
politiques elle est tranchée de toute
façon par les lois de financement de la
vie politique il est absolument interdit
ce serait un don de personnes morales et
donc c'est totalement interdit donc vous
dites qu'il ya une stratégie d'influencé
est ce que vous répondez à ça alors
alors ça dépend des des sujets
évidemment nous en fait alors ce par
rapport à un besoin qui a exprimé
mission par mission ans j'irai nous en
gros on formule des recommandations et
sur la base de ces recommandations et
bien les clients vont décider de ce
qu'ils vont choisir comme scénario il
est vrai que parfois dans la façon de
présenter les différentes options il
peut y avoir un billet de présentation
et ça c'est une réalité parce que les
consultants sont aussi des personnes
humaines et donc il peut y avoir une
forme d' influence qui peut s'exercer
dans est compris dans la formulation de
propositions ça c'est une réalité et
d'ailleurs on l'a reconnu sans problème
mais c'est ce qui se passe aussi dans
secteur privé et c'était pas ma question
alors dsk en offrant une prestation
cherche à gagner de l'influencé auprès
des politiques et donc de diddy trouver
son intérêt de business alors
aujourd'hui quand on fait le vomit son
propos non la loire effectivement de de
s'en servir comme référence donc ça
c'est un point intéressant donc c'est
exactement ce que vous avez signifier
donc c'est quelque chose qui peut tout à
fait avoir un intérêt par exemple mon
cabinet a réalisé ils sont pro bono pour
réfléchir à comment on peut déployer les
bornes de véhicules électriques dans
tout le pays donc là c'était la
modélisation de flux pour une mobilité
non programmés il ya est bien à sa façon
l'état n'a pas forcément vocation à voir
son infrastructure de véhicules
électriques et donc on a fait cette
mission là pour gérer réunir l'ensemble
de la filière et avoir une discussion
autour du sujet
ça pose aussi la question de l'
influence politique des cabinets de
concert que quand on parle par exemple
d'une réforme d'un ministre qui veut
lancer une réforme qui va chercher
l'expertisé ou l'aide d'un cabinet de
conseil à quel point le cabinet de
conseil influe sur le contenu de ce qui
est de la politique pure ou est ce que
je veux dire oui ça je suis un peu
circonspect là dessus les cabinets on a
priori on
surtout pour objet de gagner de l'argent
1 ce qui est au près n'importe quoi
forcément faire de la politique a priori
non alors on peut évidemment de manière
un peu plus large c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure on peut leur prêter
l'intention d'être plutôt en faveur de
politiques libérales de flexibilité du
marché et par voie de conséquence de
manière indirecte de répondre à à ce que
souhaitent les entreprises d'une manière
générale ça c'est passant pas forcément
de l'oubli on part oui et puis c'est
d'abord ce ne sont pas des effectivement
sont pas des gros mots c'est pas
tellement la puissance des cabinets qui
font redouter c'est la faiblesse de
l'état a encore une fois moi je le jure
vient à ce thème là c'est à dire que le
recours un peu par facilité en effet de
temps en temps à des consultants peut
être la recherche d'une légitimité qui
est qui est défaillante ou bien la
recherche de solutions qu'on a du mal à
trouver bien il ya un bon cas d'école
qui est d'ailleurs dans le dans le
rapport du sénat la crise sanitaire le
tout début de la crise sanitaire
l'appel alors l'occurrence mckinsey qui
travaille aussi pour un labo qui
s'appelle pfizer enfin bon voilà donc ça
pose une peut-être d'autres questions de
conflit d'intérêt je ne sais pas mais
mais est ce que c'est parce que l'état
se dit je sais pas gérer l'urgence je
vais pas jamais m'en sortir tout seul
quand comment vous l'analysez il ya
plusieurs niveaux en fait il ya des
choses que l'état ne dans cette crise
sanitaire ne savais absolument pas faire
de toute façon depuis depuis longtemps
il ya une question de montée en charge
ultra rapide là aussi vous êtes face à
l'urgence bon bah je regarde mes dents
c'est dans ces cas là on va au plus où
on pare au plus pressé et si la
meilleure solution disponible aller sur
le marché on va la prendre je trouve ça
logique on était vraiment dans une
situation de tension fait de faire je
rappelle qu'il fallait quand même les
hôpitaux étaient saturées etc après
est-ce que ça a révélé aussi de manière
indéniable c'est que on a laissé des
pans entiers
du système sanitaire se paupériser ça
c'est vrai on l'a vu en termes à la fois
de moyens de ressources et aussi en
termes d'organisation c'est à dire qu'on
a vu que le système des agences
régionales de santé n'étaient pas assez
réactifs savait pas bien gérer les
crises donc on s'est retrouvé dans le
très très court terme à devoir gérer une
situation révélatrice de difficultés
structurelles c'est ça le vrai problème
est alors je reviens quand même à skis
et on a un tutti des salles sparadrap
des macros sa réponse en terme de
communication laetitia est cru quand on
voit que c'est pas simple non c'est pas
simple on voit surtout une fébrilité du
président sortant et quand je vous
écoute monsieur et vous aussi je me dis
ok c'est un système qui existe qui est
finalement pas si développé que cela
quand on regarde nos voisins européens
qui existe depuis surtout nicolas
sarkozy qui dans les pays anglo-saxons
et bien plus développé qu'en france ok
alors où est le problème et quand
j'écoute la réponse du gouvernement qui
s'est faite en plusieurs temps d'abord
on a envoyé au front sur la question des
impôts parce que c'est la plus sensible
bruno le maire qui a écouté on n'a pas
de leçon à avoir sur l'évasion fiscale
ça fait cinq ans qu'on lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale ok mais ensuite quand
on voit emmanuel macron parce que c'est
lui qui va dans un deuxième temps
prendre la parole c'est lui candidat à
sa réélection qui va répondre et on sent
que l'équipe il lui même est fébrile
pourquoi parceque ils savent que cette
polémique peut enfler à tort ou à raison
et en tout cas lui coller cette
étiquette du président des riches est
peut-être ce parfum de scandale d'état
qui est scandé par toute l'opposition
évidemment qui s'est engouffré et qui
est en plus amplifiée par la loupe
médiatique il faut absolument s'en
écarter le plus possible on a dit tout
dix jours du premier tour écoutez la
réponse d'emmanuel macron c'était sur le
plateau de france 3 dimanche dernier 1
il n'y a aucun contrat qui est passé
dans la république sans qu'ils
respectent la règle des marchés publics
mise en concurrence transparence
responsabilité de celles et ceux qui
signent donc tout est clair là-dessus
dame est donc oui sinon c'est du pénal
d'accord et donc que quiconque a la
preuve qu'il ya une manipulation met le
contrat en cause au pénal alors sur
article de l'article non paiement par
don de l'impôt sur les autres avec la
fois très clair parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'ils avaient combine ces
faux
bond après chacun jugera je ne suis pas
certaine que cette fermeté cette
agressivité du chef de l'état puisqu'il
a encore président soit la bonne ça
rappelle je sais pas on est dans un
autre registre mais qui viennent me
chercher vous savez sur sur la sphère
benalla maintenant c'est qu'ils aillent
au pénal bon je rappelle encore une fois
qu'on est à dix jours du premier tour
ensuite il a un peu mis de l'eau dans
son vin emmanuel macron il a repris
votre argument en disant écoutez par
exemple pendant la pandémie on était
dans une situation d'extrême urgence il
fallait aller vite on cuit on a eu
recours au cabinet conseil argument
repris hier en conférence de presse par
amylin montchalin holly olivier du soft
ok sauf que cette ce millefeuille de
communication est troublant pourquoi
parce qu'à partir du moment où le
principal responsable prend en son nom
cette communication de crise
c'est-à-dire emmanuel macron pourquoi
envoyer les autres pourquoi envoyer les
lieux moment paradoxalement ça peut
donner
ça peut renforcer de soupçons aux moyens
thomas donc je pense que c'est une
mauvaise stratégie et qu'encore une fois
je le disais au début de cette chronique
cette étiquette de président des riches
à tort ou à raison risque de lui peut
peser pour le premier tour on verra bien
quel sera l'impact de cette polémique
dans dix ans il aura certainement mêmes
macron l'occasion de répondre de nouveau
parce qu'on a bien vu que cette
polémique tu étais pas en train de
s'éteindre de répondre de nouveau à ces
questions autour de l' usage des
cabinets de conseils de ses liens
puisque y ait eu d'autres articles avec
le cabinet mckinsey merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant qui était posée même si les
opinions étaient étaient tranchées
gilles clavel je rappelle le titre de
votre livre dans le silence de l'état
aux édition de l'observatoire et puis
votre article anton rouget est
évidemment à lire sur le site de
mediapart jeu